-Chris and I are about to play
a game called "Slapjack."
It works the same as blackjack,
but at the end of each round,
the winner gets to slap
the loser across the face
with a giant prosthetic hand.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The first to win three rounds
is the winner.
We take turns dealing.
[ Slap! ]
If it's a tie -- [ Laughs ]
If it's a tie, the dealer loses.
Chris is our guest.
You're going to deal first.
Two cards each.
Loser gets slapped.
Here we go.
-Up.
-No, up to you.
-It's the second time
I've played blackjack.
-Up.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
All right. So I -- Hit me.
Don't hit me, but hit me, right?
Hit me, baby, one more time.
-That's good.
-That's fantastic.
19. I'm going to stay, man.
-Great.
-Yeah. Beat 19.
Oops.
-It's a push!
-What does that mean?
-Dealer loses.
-Dealer loses. [ Laughs ]
Dude, you're going to be so
great on "Saturday Night Live."
I'm so psyched.
I can't wait to watch.
[ Laughter ]
[ Slap! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
I went easy on you.
I went easy on you there.
All right. Here we go.
-All right. Oh, right.
-Yeah, I got it.
-Do you know how to do it?
-No.
-No?
-Up.
And then...down.
-Down.
-Up?
-I don't know. Up.
-And then...down.
-Down.
-And then...
-Then...
-...up!
12! Loser! [ Laughs ]
Wait. Ready?
Come on!
Ooh. 16.
-Hit me.
22!
[ Laughter ]
-Are we only playing to 2?
[ Slap! ]
-Yeah!
Ahh!
-22.
Look at that.
Look at the slo-mo there.
All right. That's --
We're playing one more?
Playing -- That was ridiculous.
All right. Let's play one more.
And we'll see --
Whoever wins this, this is
worth all the points.
-Can you deal?
-No.
-Aw, man.
-This is very good. Ready?
-Yep. Up.
-Down. Up.
And then down.
[ Laughter ]
We are the worst
at playing blackjack.
All right. Here we go.
Hit me.
Gosh!
[ Slap! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Slap! ]
Chris Pine, everybody!